how's Gomes my name is welcome to the
episode 3 of wolf among us
alright press let's continue this bad
boy we're back at the bar huh this whole
thing is complete [__] and always
Aspen I mean what's his job he lost his
arm yes [__] from reaching the woodlands
Jack I don't know where they are you're
a bar you're supposed to have darts
around and I normally do but who knows
where the [__] they went to after uh-oh
he came straight no what does eschews me
come on Holly
I need entertainment I hope we get to
tear off his other arm this will do
drink eat fight you can't relax ok ok I
know just relax not here to start
anything
ok
miss white I heard you had kind of a
strange morning it's been kind of a
strange morning for everyone I think
every time I see this guy he seems to
lose weight it's amazing it really is he
loses weight and yet somehow keeps all
the muscle Jack wolfy my dear how are
you I shipped them so much is that a jar
of eggs because you know we were just
talking about you all of us at the bar
hear about you now narrow yeah not in
the mood right now well I was in the
mood to play darts
so I guess nobody's getting what they
want I'm dying to hear about the body
that came out of the East River this
morning it's none able right god damn
business everyone knows
Tweedledee was just here
he said it looked like snow white no
what what the hell
green sorry Tweedledee he said you
arrested him for no earthly reason kept
him locked in the cellar all [__]
night
he said you tortured him which I don't
know that seems like a breach of your
legislative duties baby come on you
can't be so dumb as Jack find the off
button now what is it with you two you
and gran are all let's get a posse
together when there's no one around but
as soon as the big bad wolf walks in
your tails go between your legs he
[__] maimed you aren't you pissed
yeah you got over that pretty easily cat
got your nerve what happened what
happened I'm tired is what happened
tired of what of trouble Jack I'm sick
and tired of trouble I don't want any
more so just stop revenues motor or wait
outside or [__] the hell off I don't
care what no it's fine I got a hell out
of deck yeah I'm gonna [__] the hell up
dang look to fables are dead and [__]
gren sister Holly's sister Holly's
sister has been missing for what a few
days now and we haven't heard word one
about it from anyone okay I'm gonna let
him talk actually have there been any
updates on my sister be direct your
sisters dead she's the one we found
early this morning
I guess a hack could have found a better
way to tell her no I she's fine
she doesn't care she's fine boy I sure
walked in that one if you say one more
[__] thing just one more thing yeah
shut the [__] up jack thank you god
[__] damn it of course the dear
princess no [__] white is all saintly
South where were you when we reported
this weeks ago huh where are you when we
ever [__] need you if you give one
ounce of a [__] about her about any of
us she might have been safe she might uh
uh give her some right everyone clear
out I didn't leaving her with you no way
I kind of feel like an [__]
yeah I think it's best if snow talks to
her get the [__] out of my bar
I just want should have been you it
should have been you and it wasn't
that's not very nice
we recovered this from her personal
effects I thought you might like to have
it I didn't know she still had this the
copper was from a dwarf mine it's very
rare and very old I'm gonna back off I
felt like this is now mine it's quite a
conversation grab yeah take off for a
bit would you are you sure
man those are some fancy shoes Glenn
goddamn I don't know that much about her
life honestly we didn't talk often
she was lost here in the city she just
got swept away by it
why was she glamouring him an idea why
she'd be glamorous no wife what oh god
I'm sorry why that was probably about
about what she was looking to pay down
debt it ain't me up to see you that way
eventually the only people she over at
her work you know that [__] club the
puddin and pie that's like that bad
the honor Georgie with all this [__]
fees it's a crock of [__] that's how
they kept her under their thumb really
Holly it's okay if it's too much we
don't have to do this and I don't know
why the Clank I don't [__] know we've
got a lead maybe we can take it from
here is there anything else else you can
tell us I don't think so
like I said we didn't talk much that's
all right
you've been more than helpful is she
where is she she's at the business
office she's taken care of I'm gonna
have to go down there and get her [__]
please we can handle the funeral
arrangements no no it's it's a kind of
it's a formality with trolls we burn our
dead by Sunrise or I don't know some
old-world [__] will [__] your soul
I'll check with a deputy mayor about
that he'd want to be kept in the loop
this is really important to me look why
don't you come down with me to the
business office and we'll see what we
can do they turn to snow right no I
stone right isn't that it that Club I'll
go down there now yeah see what I could
find out from the owner you were good
with her I'm impressed
really Thanks
it just made everything easier
one step closer we go into the strip
crab girl sisters and two ugly men nice
having chosen
Mary yeah that's why does it call the
pudding in the pot that booty pudding
flat Oh
sheriff what a nice surprise I'm not
sure I've seen you here before
sure you're always welcome of course is
it business or pleasure I'm looking for
something looking for some way finding
you someone is our specialty with the
clubs closed not quite what I meant
oh she's wearing one of those ribbons
that's too bad I guess you'd better talk
to Georgie you were in luck he's here
come on okay
I should warn you that Georgie does not
like to be bothered when he's working
and he's in kind of a mood right now I
mean more so than usual and I have a way
with people have a way so I've heard
why does she let me in
who is she supposed to be exactly
welcome to the pudding and pie where we
cater to the diverse taste of the fable
community there you go the pleasure is
our pleasure your desires are our
desires your imagination is the menu and
discretion is our guarantee you made me
send you you could be in danger
Oh sweetie we're all in danger Oh
goddamn it
is that what you call working what do
you think you're doing
you look like you're trying to take a
[__] hahaha but no one's gonna walk by
you [__] dozy [__] a nice guy seems
like a real Prince you do have a sense
of humor that's good
it's your face your smile you never
smile how many times you want to say it
you're supposed to turn with the nice
set to a dollar sign oh we closed
keep dancing you stop okay
let's shake you stay right there
don't even think about sitting down
we're not finished like oh [__] what at
Wyatt man sues me what are you doing
you here for a little taste tell you
what come back after midnight maybe I
can hook you up or knowing you she's
probably not quite your style you'd
prefer someone who can take a bit of a
beating tell me do you prefer a
stationary target
okay I'm not here to fight I'm not here
for that I'm not here for that just
stopped in for the chips then Jesus Big
B you're so corny I love it though no
seriously I love it the hell is over
this [__] [__]
okay all right Sheriff just [__] with
you look I know why you're here who told
you who told you listen sheriff around
here we can't afford to wait for you and
your swanky pals to take an interest we
have to look out for each other when
[__] happens I hear about it especially
if it concerns my livelihood in that
case I assumed you knew Lily was glamour
he was you're deaf get she was a troll
no I mean glamour to look like another
fable yeah well so what who gives it to
us people get up to all kinds of things
when nobody's watching it is illegal to
impersonate another fable it's roundels
illegal as long as I don't like it now
come on that's stupid not even cornea
you never provide a glamour like that
it's strictly black market stuff Oh
black market is it how exciting
this is exactly what I would expect from
a thug like you storm in throw around a
bunch of accusations try to scare people
but you've got fuchal to back it up why
would you spit on you and we're all just
meant to jump any time the wolf shows
his teeth he used to be something you
know now look at him
now [__] off get that out of my face
this was part of the glamour we found on
Lily's body take a good look
she was impersonating Snow White why
you've got this all wrong if Lily was
doing a special glamour it wasn't for me
the [__] sake I want that kind of eat
who was she doing it for then she had
clients big bit maybe one of them was
into it a lot of [__] up people in
Fable town like who try looking in the
mirror anyway now to do with me
it's gonna be a [__] so you take your
sad [__] face where I can't see it
the hell man bastard [__] [__] I
think this guy needs a good blow to
yourself man probably a little mess
it's [__] your own fault man [__]
sake the hell is that guy hansol it was
a handsome hand hold on a minute
Hans is it Hannes just cleans up and
provides a little muscle when we need it
he's not gonna know anything about the
girls and their clients or any of that
no one knows don't you get it it's by
design discretion is our guarantee right
and the way we guarantee now is that no
one knows anything they don't have to
know including me I cover my eyes and
take my coat end of story
why not look it up what's that isn't
there a little book with all the stuff
about the girls and all that written in
a [__] [__] Oh Mira is no book and
as for you hands we need to work on your
crowd trouble it hasn't got anywhere to
start hey that's my personal property
oh go ahead do what comes naturally
alright yeah we're gonna play in the big
bad wolf part you're unbelievable break
hey no I want that birch cut the crap
Georgie I want the book Hans is talking
about ants is confused again
don't even think about it look Georgie
why don't you just tell me where the
book is can we please not go round and
round about this there's no book and I
already know there's a [__] book come
on not touch that um II must not have to
do with you
this try and controlling who well
hollows this looks like a floor safe I
wouldn't know it was here when we moved
in I don't have a key to it sheriff
would he come on
[__] sake I've got to open up in a few
hours give me the book Last Chance man
that's [__] chains give it to me
you're the big bad bastard we get it
everyone's guilty we [__] get it
Jesus you're killing me
I'm begging you I'll pay two women are
dead and quit being a bloody idiot come
on it's leave it there's nothing there
for you I don't want to ruin this place
I just wanted to give me the [__]
book I don't know I might want to stand
back all right all right
Ariella finally
hell I went pretty well woody come on
men
hey I'm coming dress my business over
this [__]
protector of Fabletown my ass what a
load of crap once again don't get your
hopes up there's nothing in here that
will tell you anything what is it kick
to the balls for me and my club so we
can be happy about that
all right we got our evidence we're
ready to make a pact for wait here this
is Lilly's last entry
so tell me Georgie who's this mr. Smith
oh dear I'm afraid it might be a fake
name big bit secrecy is sort of how this
all works even aunts knows that maybe
how much to save room number I don't
[__] know millimeters maybe don't
[__] me Georgie this is your book
your girl my [__] secretary I give
them a stage I give them music I provide
an erotic venue to attract and retain
clients but let's be clear on something
the girls make the arrangements with
their clients not health at all but
girls they're the ones with the mr.
Smith's and Joneses and mr. X types
whatever happens outside the club that's
on them I love the business take my coat
and I'm out now about quite an offer you
and your bullying excuse me while I call
you superiors to make a complaint
so we should I check with the Han
counsel's office for the girl I'd say we
shake with the girl I bet she knows plus
there might be you know some evidence
all right well I saw Lily oh it's empty
[__] what is this oh my god I should put
these on dick lipgloss compact glitter
faith thanks for covering for me tonight
let's talk before you go over to the
apart so they knew each other looks like
they both saw one of Lily's clients
excuse me I heard you out there yeah I
don't remember ever seeing you here
before I'm here now I'm here now yes
you're trying to place me this man they
used to call me the Little Mermaid no
way
once upon a time does that help
what do they call you now what do they
call you now whatever makes them happy
my name is Nerissa well Nerissa I've got
some questions of course you do I don't
have answers you'll have to find those
yourself well I think you might have
some answers to us haven't forgotten
over 2:07 mean anything to you I assumed
it was a room number but where we can't
talk about work come on just [__]
tell me is a murder case yeah I mean
can't these lips are sealed
discretion is our guarantee why do they
keep saying that it's how things work
here people keep using those phrases
what does it mean yeah this is what I
need to know about Lily's last entry
who's mr. Smith where's room 207
I have to know these lips oh it's a
spell it's a spell
sheriff Wolfe would you like to make an
appointment with me
so she will show me okay what would I
need a hundred and fifty it's not good
to be short I can't just give her her
what can we have this isn't enough but
it's all I've got
wait here for a second
I don't know why she's getting here
she's like I might shake my titties for
him they made out for a second oh so it
is a room number huh not 207 you get the
point
you'll think of something yeah the open
arms hmm this is where they met enjoy
your stay
I hope you find what you're looking for
so some of the weight she's going boom
and that's kind of obvious I guess
made them cry
ha ha ha ha
oh this is right next door disagree all
right and into the hotel we shall go
live like you enjoy watching as always
Bruce thanks for clicking that button I
appreciate it makes you feel better if
you do it I think maybe you'll have to
click to find out ha ha ha ha ha but
anyway I'll see you tomorrow with the
new episodes as always thanks for
watching this one's for you
you